CAMPAIGN DIRECTLY TIES THEM TO
THE ECONOMY AND JOBS.
>> Brian: RIGHT.
DANA, A FOX NEWS ALERT RIGHT
NOW, WE ARE ALSO HEARING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS REMOVING BRAD
PARSCALE AS CAMPAIGN MANAGER.
"NEW YORK TIMES" SAYS HE’S BEEN
DEMOTED.
HAVE YOU CONFIRMED THIS, HAVE
YOU HEARD ANYTHING ABOUT THIS?
WE HAVE NOT HEARD MUCH FROM HIM
LATELY.
>> YES, I THINK THE PRESIDENT
HAS ACTUALLY PUT OUT A STATEMENT
AS WELL, TWITTER HAS BEEN MESSED
UP BUT HE PUT OUT A STATEMENT ON
FACEBOOK, I ACTUALLY HAVE IT
HERE.
HE’S PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE THAT
BILL STEP, HE MOVED OVER TO THE
CAMPAIGN JUST A COUPLE MONTHS
AGO, WILL BECOME THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN MANAGER AND BRAD IS
GOING TO BE HANDLING ALL THE
ADDITIONAL WORK THAT HE WAS
KNOWN FOR AND FAMOUS FOR IN 2016
AND WILL REMAIN A SENIOR ADVISOR
ON THE CAMPAIGN.
I THINK BRAD IS TO BE ADMIRED,
HE’S DONE A LOT TO GET THE
CAMPAIGN TO WHERE IT IS TODAY.
BUT I THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT
RECOGNIZING THAT THIS ELECTION
IS GOING TO BE DIFFERENT FROM
2016 HAD TO MAKE THIS CHANGE OR
WANTED TO MAKE THIS CHANGE, YOU
HAVE TO ADMIRE BRAD FOR BEING
WILLING TO SUCH PRIDE ASIDE AND
STICK WITH THE TEAM AND WORK
WITH THEM TO TRY TO BEACH
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> Brian: HE’S RAISED A LOT OF
MONEY, BUT THE GROUND WORK
TOGETHER, BUT THE TEAM TOGETHER
BUT MAYBE THE PRESIDENT WANT
SOMEBODY WITH MORE EXPERIENCE TO
BRING THEM OVER THE NEXT FOUR
MONTHS.
HE’S NEVER SHY ABOUT MAKING A
CHANGE WITH THIS CAMPAIGN OR
THIS ADMINISTRATION.
AND WE KNOW THAT BRAD PARSCALE
WAS PUT THERE BY A VOLGA TRUMP
AND JARED KUSHNER AND THEY
PLAYED MAJOR ROLES WITH THE